[Music]
either you're going to a wedding or you
have dressed up for us
i did dress up for you guys i am i'm
wearing this for a couple reasons okay
reasons one i'm so excited to be here
this is like
so excited that's so nice such a huge
fan thank you like a dream of mine so i
thought i would dress up thank you so
much that's very cool thank you and then
the other reason is i thought um happy
endings would get more awards
consideration than it did
so i spent seven thousand dollars on a
tuxedo
and so i was like i should probably wear
it yeah yeah and then um the other
another reason is that i noticed that
you guys are usually more dressed up
than the guests we are a lot of guests
they're cool and they come on and
they're dressed like skater punks yeah
so i thought maybe you guys could relax
you guys could relax tonight i feel
i feel relaxed yeah good yeah i feel
like a slob now yeah
it looks good then i've done my job
you've done your job and you've done it
well and then um
and then more yeah yeah
you've got many reasons i'm going to do
a type 10 about the tux
[Laughter]
and then i just you know i also thought
it would be
a funny bit to wear a tux and i was
obviously wrong like way around
no you were right it's fantastic oh
thank you you look good uh let's talk
about happy endings uh this show is
growing and growing in popularity people
really like it yeah yeah uh it's a very
funny show
your character
you play uh a character who is gay on
the show
uh but it's interesting there's a lot of
stereotypical choices that people actors
can make if they're playing someone gay
you do not make the stereotypical
choices no the character i play i i
always liken him to like the the frat
dude that you went to college with
that's like let's go out and party
except
instead of like scoring chicks he's into
like uh penis
and he's like very
and like he's very open about that you
know and there's no difference with him
you know everyone's like you know let's
go out and party tonight he's like yeah
and hopefully there'll be some dudes
there okay
with with penises yes um
if that happens to be the case i'm sure
he wouldn't be upset so it's funny
because you're very your character is
very laid back yes in a very comical way
is that coming from you are you a
laid-back person i think i am i think
i'm actually more laid-back than my
character i i think that i'm
personality-wise like the closest you
could get to matthew mcconaughey while
still being jewish
[Laughter]
you were the jewish matthew mcconaughey
the jewish matthew mcconaughey i have no
problem saying that yeah i am the jewish
matthew mcconaughey like um
you know as jewish
as cool and laid back as you can be
while still feeling a chill in the air
in most diners
so so okay so the other thing is uh you
uh your character
enjoys to partake
marijuana is that something that uh is
that a yeah i i i am pro marijuana
um that's all right
yeah uh i hope now i'm gonna get audited
i feel like i said that not in
california no that's right everybody
when cops pull you over on the highway
they're smoking pot
this state is insane yeah i got pulled
over for not having a dank enough sativa
[Laughter]
uh okay well one thing i've noticed is
that you're a lot of actors they have to
starve themselves and they're you know
you see them they're always eating a
salad because they got to be so skinny
your character
is kind of it's seems like she's
supposed to be kind of a little soft in
the middle yes i they refer constantly
to my dismay to my character as fat or
chubby um which i thought you know when
i got the job would be great but then i
think after the show got picked up they
were like maybe you should try to lose a
little weight
so i tried
and
and very quickly they were like you know
what forget that just don't die
and i was like i think i can handle that
but now i feel like it's odd like now
that the show's been on for um a couple
years and like we're starting to get
into more like my character as a
boyfriend now
no matter who they cast it turns out to
be like a gay kevin james situation
right right
i feel like you're getting locked into
that yeah i am i am kevin james to
whatever like super hunky guy they bring
in to be my boyfriend and everyone is
wondering like how that guy ended up
with this fat slob no you see that's
just low self-esteem totally yeah why do
you think i'm here begging for you guys
to clap at me i mean yeah there's a
reason that well it's gonna be fine